bonjour
les formations et les vaches oui c'est
d'aller de norvège j'aurai des fromages
à pâte molle pardonner ferme
un rapport
c'est mon gars n'a pas écarté la fermer
ça fait maintenant 22 ans que la famille
elle rit transforme son lait en
différents fromages fermiers on est très
fiers surtout qu'on a gagné quelques
prix avec nos fromages
le marché va très bien aussi on a
beaucoup une belle clientèle locale
aussi une au fromage se retrouve un peu
partout au québec et un peu aussi dans
le reste du canada aussi monsieur alary
a vu l'industrie fromagère et des
consommateurs évolué ces vingt dernières
années nous notre pain fromage c'est un
rassemble de jeunes gens qu'on voulait
faire découvrir les bleus aux québécois
à ce moment là leur semble juste un but
très doux religions y avait le plus
l'hôte et là ils veulent quelque chose
de plus goûteuse qui va les surprendre
vous savez avant tout moi j'ai apporté
des fromages dans l'arène eaux-de-vie
tank depuis les années 2000 je fais que
des fromageries du québec fromage cdr
représente près d'une trentaine de
fromagers artisans du québec et du
canada lors nos des produits incroyables
n'a plus rien à envier aux fromages
européenne on a notre place pire on
l'apprend bien même son cloche chez les
plus gros producteurs comme un crew pur
le consommateur québécois et le
consommateur canadien mais
particulièrement le consommateur
québécois est vraiment très ouvert à
essayer des nouveaux fromages fins et à
découvrir des nouveaux fromages pains
mais les chemins parcourus n'a pas
toujours été sans embûches la crise de
la listériose débat elle évolue
malheureusement d'un côté ça peut être
exagéré met de côté la population à part
donc à pas de chance à prendre en 2008
la crise de la listériose a été un coup
terrible pour cette industrie et début
quelques temps les ententes commerciales
avec l'europe et les états unis
augmentent la compétition sur les
tablettes d'épicerie et voilà qu'une
nouvelle crise touche nos fromages et
les augmentations sont féroces comme
jamais vécu de ma vie depuis le 1er
février le lait coûte 8 % de plus
évidemment l'impact se fait sentir sur
le prix des fromages c'est la période la
plus plate de ma vie dans l'alimentation
parce que c'est la plus grosse
augmentation que je subis depuis que ce
fait pas de 30h dans le fromage et qui
va payer ce prix là le fabricant un
distributeur
la bannière où le consommateur la seule
personne qui est en bout de ligne va
payer la facture c'est le consommateur
sont comme peints choix de laisser les
fromageries exécuter les détails hier on
continue à prendre leurs marges qui sont
destinés à leurs coûts d'opération puis
le consommateur va au bout de ligne
payer la résultante de l'augmentation du
lei des êtres 1 puis le tout le reste
est pourquoi le consommateur devrait-il
être le seul absorber cette hausse vous
allez devoir augmenter de combien ben on
peut-être qu'en moyenne entre 5 et 8%
nous on n'a aucun contrôle le tube une
fois notre fragile sortie du sida chaque
boutique chaque épicerie fait ce qu'il
veut si les autres intervenants emprunte
plus là on n'a pas de contrôle de tulle
c'est mais par contre
si le prix du lait a augmenté de plus de
8% est ce que automatiquement mon
fromage vont coûter vite pour simplifier
pas nécessairement cd calculer un petit
peu plus compliqué mais inévitablement
l'ingrédient numéro un pour faire du
fromage c'est du lait il faut 10 litres
de lait pour faire un kilo de fromage
donc bien sûr avec une augmentation de
10% du prix du lait inévitablement il ya
un impact sur les fromages
d'autres fromages et part d'une
augmentation de coûts de production
pouvant aller jusqu'à 18% il n'y a pas
que le lait qui coûte plus cher les
intrants comme l'emballage le transport
la main d'oeuvre font aussi exploser le
prix c'est inquiétant pour de petites
fromageries s'inquiéta la résultats du
consommateur qui va s'en aller vers un
choix de fromages européens
peu importe la provenance avec des
écarts de prix plus marquée
qu'est ce que vont faire nos grandes et
ailleurs sont le support
des négociations sont en cours entre les
détaillants les fabricants et les
distributeurs pour s'entendre sur un
prix qui permettrait à chacun d'absorber
les coûts engendrés et de minimiser
l'augmentation du prix pour le
consommateur
moi ça fait quand même plusieurs années
que je suis dans l'institut lum sa
première fois j'entendais parler que
lors la relation avec les détaillants et
les transformateurs étaient telles que
les gens disaient ben s'il faut on va à
l'été livrer parce que d'or moi je
progresse de bourg et mes coups ça donne
rien de livrer
des produits ont effectivement été
retirés des tablettes momentanément seul
pouvoir de négociation disent les
fromagers ce qui provoque de
l'instabilité quand on prie et à la
disponibilité des produits déjà en
épicerie on a pu constater des eaux sur
certains fromages allant de 12 à près de
50% mais les grandes chaînes refusent de
nous expliquer comment les prix peuvent
augmenter autant si les producteurs ne
propose pas de telles augmentations
francis mailly et porte-parole des
grandes chaînes d'alimentation comme
sobey's l'aube la métro costco et
walmart s'est décarcassée des
discussions comme je dis qu'ils sont en
lien avec les stratégies commerciales à
ce que les détaillants vont revoir vont
adapter leur stratégie commerciale en ce
sens vu la grande demande de ces
produits là et l'attachement ces
produits là c'est des choses qui sont
possibles mais que telle a cessé d
entente cd en tant que privé que que moi
même je n'ai pas accès en parlant non
l'industrie de chacun des membres niveau
avec avec ses intérêts avec qui avec ses
volontés ce qui va atténuer entre
guillemets le risque pour les fromages
québécois c'est que tous les fromages
vont augmenter tous les produits qu'ils
viennent d'europe qui viennent des états
unis où qu'il soit fait au québec vont
augmenter en raison de l'inflation mais
en raison du prix du lait le pire
scénario sais c'est qu'on est des
mauvaises ou des mauvais résultats
versus le consommateur qui décide que le
prix trop élevés puis qu'ils s'en
aillent vers d'autres types de produits
plus industrialisés pu importer
puisse allah un impact négatif chez nos
petits fromagers suis pas inquiet pour
les moyens je suis plus inquiet pour les
petits fromagers
c'est grâce au travail de tout le monde
dans l'industrie des grands comme des
plus petits joueurs qui ont tous
travaillé dans les vingt dernières
années pour vraiment bâtir cette
industrie avec fierté et pour porter
haut les couleurs des fromages québécois
donc je crois vraiment que on est
beaucoup mieux outillés aujourd'hui pour
faire face à cette augmentation ou sa
roue à 7 à ce contexte de marché très
particulier que l'on pouvait l'être il
ya 20 ans
qu'est ce que le consommateur c'est ce
qu'on sait pas cessé
je ne sais pas ce qu'est ce qu'on va
faire savoir afin de conserver des
problèmes mais problème
province avaient toutes les voix magique
problèmes légaux
moi ce que je souhaite c'est
consommateur reste fidèle à ses produits
locaux que la consommation se poursuivre
puis qu'on finisse par trouver un bon
équilibre avec nos clients qui sont des
partenaires dans cette mise à marcher là
mais il faut trouver un bon équilibre
pour que l'ensemble des maillons de la
chaîne peuvent trouver dans la tabbee
lite est satisfaisant qui continue à
livrer un produit de qualité comme le
consommateur
[Musique]